did i tell you about uh
the fact that uh deceivers
have a slightly higher pitch to their
voice do you know anything about the
physiological mechanisms is that a
stress response or did anybody study why
that is it's stress
due to
fear of detection okay
that's believed to
cause you to to contract your
your belly uh when you're making a sound
and so it it it rises in pitch
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to have
with me dr robert trivers
dr trivers is an evolutionary biologist
who concentrates on social theory based
on natural selection and on evolutionary
genetics these happen to be the
backbones of all biology his early work
focused on reciprocal ultra altruism
which we will talk about in some detail
today the evolution of sex differences
in all species the sex ratio at birth
parent offspring conflict kinship and
sex ratio and social insects and the
theory and a theory outlining the nature
of self-deception and its operation in
the service of deceit which in itself
can confer however temporarily certain
advantages
he then devoted 15 years of his life
with austin burt to reviewing the vast
topic of selfish genetic elements in all
species except bacteria and viruses
these are genes that do not benefit the
individual with the genes but spread
because they have a within individual
selective advantage
in 2011 he published a popular book
deceit and self-deception fooling
yourself the better to fool others
published in the u.s as the folly of
fools it's been translated into 11
languages including korean chinese and
taiwanese and
is widely regarded as a definitive
treatment of the subject in 2015 he
published a personal memoir wildlife
adventures of an evolutionary biologist
translated into spanish and polish a
side note dr trivers also served as the
undergraduate advisor to dr heather hang
and dr brett weinstein who are both well
known to the audience that frequents
these dialogues
welcome dr trivers it's very good of you
to agree
to talk with me today
thank you sir
so i thought
my my pleasure i thought we'd talk we'd
start with reciprocal altruism there'll
be lots of people who are listening and
watching that don't know what that means
and it's a crucial idea and so i'd like
you to outline well first to define it
and then to outline your thoughts about
it if you would
well um
wd hamilton
who i always regarded as the only
greater social theorists
evolutionary social theorists than
myself
had already laid out in 1964
in detail
the argument for altruistic behavior
so-called
altruistic is something that
lowers your own reproductive success
called fitness but i never liked the
term fitness
because it had connotations
that uh
uh could get in the way of your
understanding whereas reproductive
success directly described what we're
talking about
the number of surviving i'll offering
you you left so an altruistic act is one
which lowers
your production of surviving offspring
and raises
the production of surviving offspring
of the recipient
of your altruism
now if you're related
then the gene or genes involved
may enjoy a net benefit
so
indeed you're related to your children
typically by a half
and yet you invest in them
uh
as
as a key
vehicle to your reproductive success but
uh hamilton extended the
system laterally so nephews and nieces
might not be direct descendants of yours
but still
you could be related to them by
a quarter let's say
in which case the benefit would have to
be greater than four times the cost
for the
behavior to be selected
so so that was
that was uh
the first step
now it occurred to me
and that was
uh when i started becoming a biologist
in 1967
uh i took a year as a special student
uh at harvard to make up for the
complete lack of
an undergraduate education biology
and was then accepted into graduate
school
in any case
i thought it was obvious
that there was a second kind of altruism
in which
i did something nice for you
and that at a certain point in the
future
you did something nice back to me
so it was reciprocal and as long as
benefits were greater than costs
which one assumes they would be
otherwise you wouldn't be selected under
any regime
for them
then
there could be a net benefit
of this transfer
the problem
with reciprocal altruism was
what happens with the so-called cheater
that is
the system automatically selects for
someone that receives the benefit
but doesn't bother reciprocate
well
if they don't reciprocate at all
you cut off any future altruism toward
them and so
each act of
failure on their part results in a
source of autism being cut off so the
more interesting phenomena
is where you cheat
that is you give back less
than you got
but you're still giving back a benefit
so
they still
receive a benefit they just don't
receive
the benefit that they quote ought to
or would if the
uh
system was egalitarian
and fair
and those words fair
and just and so on i felt
actually emerged
from
reciprocal altruism
precisely because
they evaluated
uh the costs
uh
inflicted versus the benefits received
so you had subtle cheaters
which
reciprocated to a degree
and enough so that you enjoy the net
benefit but not as much as you quote
deserved
and so that was a dynamic
of reciprocal altruism
was the the cheater
uh
detector
detection of this right so
wasn't so difficult
but uh
how to interact with the individual
so it's to change his or her behavior
that was an inter more interesting
uh problem
so uh
a colleague i think a graduate student
at harvard
had happened to write
a paper
reviewing the emotions
associated with altruistic behavior
he didn't have any particular
theoretical orientation or evolutionary
but
[Music]
he reviewed
the subject
and i remember going to him
i took a class on morality something
like that
specifically in order to learn
enough
about
human behavior related to reciprocity to
flesh out my
paper
but uh their
uh
first class i saw
that the graduate student who was a
teaching assistant had already written a
paper
uh doing exactly
what i hoped to
learn by sitting in on the class
so i went to him
and asked if i could uh
sit and read his paper
let's say in his office and take notes
and he said uh hell i'll give you a copy
and i thought uh almighty god
uh that's an act of altruism
that i can surely benefit from and so he
gave me a copy i promptly dropped out of
the course
and
actually
uh molded
the
second half by eevee
the the content of my paper
uh in the different categories were just
drawn straight out of his work
and reorganized
a bit so as to fit
the logic i was pushing
i hope that's not so too complicated or
too much detail no
no no it's it's exactly right so so
why
concentrate specifically on reciprocal
altruism i mean obviously tied up in
that is is is cooperation mutual benefit
and then also you discuss the problem of
cheating and cheating deception or
detecting cheating and deception of
course is a way of making cheating
difficult to detect and so you're you're
focusing your biological inquiry on
what we would intuit as moral issues
moral issue
associated with cooperation the moral
issue associated with deviation from
that cooperation
is that a reasonable way of looking at
what you're what you've been doing
uh well what i did
uh when you say what i've been doing
i actually did
write a paper called reciprocal altruism
30 years later
and tried to uh
um bring the subject up to date
but in general
i didn't do that on any of my papers
that is i wrote the paper
and that was it
i wrote a paper on parent offspring
conflict
i don't think i've ever written a second
one
i wrote a paper on haploid diploidin the
evolution of social insects
uh where
i i took
kinship theory hamilton's kinship
they're in applied rigorously
to the unusual situation of ants bees
and wasps where males are only have one
set of chromosomes they're aployed and
females have two they're diploid and
that leads to unusual degrees of
relatedness
indeed
it's the only case
in nature
other than
identical twinning
where you're more related
to someone other than your own offspring
namely
uh
full sisters
in the haplodiploids system you're
related to them by three-quarters
but you're only related to your brothers
by one quarter
so it cancels out to give you
half
and that's how
people thought about it for
a couple of years but it's obvious to me
that uh
uh you don't average them
if one is three quarters and the other
is a quarter then you're selected to
invest
much more heavily
in those that you're related
by three quarters
and much less than those that are you're
related to by one quarter
how do you envision the relationship
between
reciprocal altruism and
the structures of society and the moral
structures that guide society
i mean i would almost be thinking off
the top of my head it's been quite some
time
since i've thought about it
uh you mentioned in your introduction
that i peeled off
15 years of my life or whatever it was
to master selfless genetic elements
that's
selection
below the level of the individual
hamilton was conscious of it
uh but uh
it was austin burt my co-author
who was the first to see
uh really deeply into the literature
and start to reorganize it
so the entire subject of
genetics
evolutionary genetics
was reorganized around the concept
of
selfish genes and the conflict they have
with others
uh both between closely related
individuals and within individuals
so now you're asking me
the relationship between reciprocal
altruism and
sort of
society-wide phenomenon and so on
and i can't i can't boil it down
to a simple argument yep
in
2002 which was the selected papers of
robert servers
not to collect it because it wasn't
worth
everything
uh just as selected but i did something
uh
unique
generally for selected or collected
papers people would write a a short
introduction
to how they happen to write the paper
and then you would get the paper
and then there would be a short
introduction for your next paper
and then the paper
what i added
was what you're asking for which is uh
i would write a short introduction then
the paper
then there would be a short section on
progress since then
uh since the paper is published
that was often
fairly brief
and
i can't remember what i said about uh
reciprocal autism now i
i would have to go get the book
to uh
to check it out
but i'm afraid i don't have
i'm afraid i can't reason for you
at the level you would like
in terms of reciprocal altruism and
societal organization and so on
i think it's obvious that societies are
not
i mean they're
they may be partly based on kinship
but uh
only partly
and and often much more
on patterns of cooperation
that uh evolve or are generated
and sustain themselves
why would you stress cooperation
as a basis for
social organizations say rather than
competition
or kinship for that matter
well i mean
i mean it's it's partly just you know
what was available at the time when i
wrote on reciprocal altruism if you want
to
if you want to bring it all the way back
to the evolution of reciprocal altruism
which was my first paper published
[Music]
and indeed harvard broke
their usual rule and they allowed me
i just had a thesis that consisted of
three chapters one was reciprocal
altruism the other was parental
investment sexual selection then harvard
had a rule that
you had to have at least one chapter
that was empirical
and that meant lab work which i had no
intention whatsoever of doing i knew
nothing about labs and i had no ability
there or field work well now field work
is a much more congenial especially if
you're interested in
social behavior social
theory so watching baboons
which i did with irv devore in
kenya and tanzania back in 72
or going to
uh
haiti and then jamaica
with my advisor ernest williams who was
the expert on tree climbing lizards
so in fact i did my third chapter
on the green lizard
uh the largest of the enolas tree
climbing lizards there's seven species
well there's really eight
uh in jamaica
uh
so i had to go back down to jamaica
at regular intervals i would come back
to harvard and
and and work for three months during the
semester teaching and so on then
you'd get a month between semesters and
i would
fly down to jamaica
and that set up a lifelong bond between
me and jamaica
where i've lived
at least 20 years of my life
uh married onto the island or stole a
woman off the island as
another jamaican expression
and uh
have four children by her
dr trivers how did you get interested in
deception and how did you get interested
in deception and then in self-deception
and the relationship between the two
let me step back one second sir
you asked about
uh competition versus cooperation
i mean you
competition even applies
between different cooperative
enterprises
they cooperate within their entity
but they compete with other
similarly structured entities
so as to maximize their
reproductive success
uh now competition
was well known
i mean it was the basis of life where
we're out there competing
all the time
uh
cooperation
was a subtler problem
which you had to figure out
what the
competitive natural selection advantage
was
so now you just asked about deceit and
self-deception but sir i'm afraid
uh
blame it on uh
78 years of mentation if you will
uh
i
do know that by 76
in other words reciprocal autism was 71.
parental investment was 72.
uh
trevors and willard
which was an interesting
theory about uh
tending to produce suns under these
conditions and then
[Music]
daughters under these conditions so for
example if you look at a human hierarchy
people at the top end
tend to produce suns
uh with higher frequency but people at
the bottom end
tend to produce daughters
at higher frequencies well
every child has a mother and a father
so we know that the aggregate
reproductive success of females
must equal
the aggregate reproductive success of
males so if high class males are doing
better
then
it makes sense that lower class
women are doing better
so it's to balance out the equation
and so they get some advantage
of uh these men
i.e they mate with them
um
now
i wrote
i wrote the forward or or something like
that
for some book in
1975 or 76 and i'm afraid to stick my
brain
but
i slipped in their
theory
of uh
deceit and self-deception there
uh just they were just two sentences in
there
something about uh
you know deceptions obviously favored
but uh
um
you know the best way to hide it
from others is first of all to hide it
from yourself
and then you don't give off any of the
cues
that
are associated with deception
incidentally
i i have paid attention to the
literature on cues
and it's very interesting to me
that the the most general
uh
cue
for deception is a slight raise in your
picture your voice
that seems to be all but universal
uh
so
if if you can listen carefully enough
to hear
when someone's voice
rises a bit
they're more likely to be practicing
deception
so
i practiced as a clinician for a long
time and as a research psychologist and
i was very interested in how people
deceived themselves and the kinds of
psychopathologies that emerged
and so here's a here's a hypothesis let
me ask you what you think of it
what i noticed often was that
when people received information that
contradicted one of their explicit
beliefs
the information often manifested itself
emotionally
and so imagine that a husband comes home
with lipstick on his collar
and the wife sees that and becomes
agitated as a consequence
but then refuses to think through what
the implications of that might be
and so the self-deception isn't
one fully thought out proposition versus
another
it's
a fully thought out set of propositions
say about marital stability
or at least partially thought out versus
an emotional cue of uncertain
significance that has to be unpacked
with difficulty and avoidance of that is
tantamount at least to some form of
self-deception
how does that structure well i i get
lost in your argument there go go back
to your example
uh
there's lipstick on his uh collar
right and now she has a vision in her
mind of
let's say marital stability and harmony
and it's pretty fleshed out
but now all she's got that contradicts
that is
one piece of visual evidence and an
emotion which might be anger anxiety and
so forth
and she can hold on to her pre-existing
belief with no work
in order to transform that belief she's
going to have to do a tremendous amount
of exploration and investigation
and so she can just not do that what is
her
pre-existing quote belief here i'm
getting lost already
it might be a fantasy of marital harmony
okay so she has a fantasy of marital
harmony she has a piece of evidence
that's inconsistent
with marital harmony
now what
well
there's a very large potential range of
meanings of that piece of evidence
and so for her to transform that into
something differentiated enough
to alter her fantasy would take a
tremendous amount of effort and so she
can just not do that
and that's
passive self-deception which i think is
the most
common
self-deception
yes you know something's up you know
there's an elephant under the carpet but
you decide not to look
so i'm getting confused now
you've already seen it
you've seen the lipstick there
so you've seen evidence
that suggests
that uh
he's in a
semi-intimate relationship with another
woman
at least to the point of kissing her
or being kissed by her
now i'm confused with what you're saying
she's put a lot of time and effort
into the theory of her marriage that she
already holds
so it's
it the idea that that marriage is stable
and loving let's say is a predicate for
many of her memories
it's a presumption for many of her
current activities and it's the basis
for her future plan
and so to investigate that means that
she would have to go through all the
work of modifying all those
representations
it's not like the evidence contains that
modification it's just an error message
it's hard to unpack an error message
what's the error message
well the error message would be the
lipstick and then the negative emotion
that goes with its with its visual
apprehension
what's the error
the error is that
the presumption of her fantasy that her
marriage is stable and loving and let's
say also monogamous
so that's an error you're saying and now
she's got a message that she's in error
so now what's uh right but that's all
she has that's the problem right and
all she has is a message that she's in
error it doesn't contain much other
information
and it's going to be extremely hard for
her to
reconstruct all that theorizing she's
done
based on the assumption
erroneous assumption of monogamy
and so it's easiest just not to do it
yes and then what's the cost of her not
doing it
well i would say the immediate cost is
virtually nothing
and that's another advantage
but the long-term cost is that she's
building a future reality
based on a mispresumption
and so
she can't she may make errors for
example about her financial security
going into the future or even the
presence of her partner
and that's a huge potential cost
she's going to underestimate for example
the danger of divorce
or of him leaving
in order to avoid facing the uh
the pain in the uh and the
yes well and i think it i think this
idea maps onto your hypothesis that
at times the right hemisphere and the
left hemisphere can be delivering
contradictory messages
so if the left is linguistic and
generates up
detailed propositional arguments let's
say that get held with some certainty
and the right emotionally signals error
then there's a tremendous amount of work
that has to be done in order to
unpack that error and remake all those
propositional
presumptions
it's really hard that's what i don't
understand
in your
argument i don't understand why there's
a huge amount of work
where she's got to unpack
a whole endless series of
assumptions or arguments
just because it is one
thing
all right let's let's go back to the the
situation
we know that the guy
is involved with at least one other
woman
and we know
that it's you know he's
tended to conceal it
uh
as would be natural
so as to uh
so as to not result in
marital conflict
now
he messes up
um
it seems to me i mean she has a simple
decision
that she confront him over it
and say
uh joe
what the hell is this
or
confront him whatever way she wants to
okay so imagine the imagine the
complexity of that confrontation
and and this is the sort of thing that i
saw a lot in my clinical practice so
because he lied about that
she no longer knows whether anything
he's told her or anything he's done
is
true
or real
it because she's violated this basic
presupposition of trust
and so part of the reason she's going to
have a
major emotional reaction to that is that
she now doesn't know whether she can
trust anything about him and
may have to reevaluate all her
perceptions of him even those that are
part of the past
yeah go ahead so what
well so there's a tremendous amount of
work associated with that
you know and part of what our
certainties do as far as i can tell is
inhibit anxiety and doubt
almost by definition
and so now if you've discovered that you
can't trust someone because they
violated a fundamental presumption
then every
every part of
the way you look at the world that's
predicated on that trust has now become
unstable
well now that that is a such a strong
statement you say everything
that is associated with
that
violation of trust
is now
subject to re-evaluation and so forth
and so on
that's
i don't know
you
you know you're
the the foundation of your argumentation
towards me
and i respect it is that you're
have clinical experience
dealing with people
who come to you
and talk to you
about these kinds of things
so you know
i think that's a good objection
and so let me
let me propose something in relationship
to that because i think that's a crucial
objection that you made
so
one of the things that i
wrestled with formulating
when i was thinking about self-deception
was the relationship of one belief to
another
so
imagine that and this is something you
could object to
imagine that some beliefs are more
fundamental than others and
that fundamentalness or
is a reflection of how many other
beliefs depend on that belief
it's like a definition of fundamentals a
hierarchy
and so
some beliefs are trivial
because almost nothing
depends on them but other beliefs are
absolutely fundamental because
everything that you're doing depends on
their validity and so
well depending on how deep the belief is
eating dinner
come on brother well okay but
fair enough good objection but you know
if you deal with someone who's
profoundly depressed
because they've something that was
crucial to them was devastated they will
often have a tremendous amount of
difficulty doing even those basic things
that's true brother i i grant you that
people can suffer to the point where
they got a problem eating
they've got a problem digesting i mean
the actual digestive system
uh may be
hindered or altered
by the kind of mental stress or
mentation that's going on
let me give you an example of that in
with depression
go ahead
so this is often what okay this this is
often what happens with people who are
very depressed let's say they have a
minor
argument with their their son someone
they love just a minor argument
and then they think
well i acted really badly in that
argument
i really hurt my son's feelings
only a terrible person would hurt
someone's feelings
i must be a terrible person
i'm a terrible person
now and i'm going to be a terrible
person in the future and there's nothing
that can be done about it
and that's the sort of thinking that
leads to suicide
and you can see the person going down
the hierarchy of their beliefs right
from from the little argument which is
nothing all the way down to something
that is so basic to their self-concept
that if it's challenged they want to die
that happens a lot into real depression
real severe depression
that happens continually it it's almost
like the hallmark of the illness
well that's that's interesting
i have been thinking about
depression
uh you know personally i was presenting
that conception of depression
you know that that cascade of doubt
that i outlined
as an illustration of what people are
motivated to avoid when they practice
self-deception
they don't want to start unraveling
because they don't know where the
unraveling will end
so they're afraid of that
and that's partly why they won't
investigate
yes i i
i
you know off the top of my head i would
agree with that kind of argument
that uh
uh
they don't want to pursue
uh reality very far
uh when it's easier to
flip flip part of it
and uh be unconscious or
uh try to become unconscious
of the flip you're making
now in
your book on self-deception you outlined
some of the social costs of
self-deception say in relationship to
warfare
and talked about the way that
the biases that we have to perhaps
reject
contradictory information
can produce catastrophic consequences
say at the policy level
said for example that leaders and the
people that they
purport to lead are often extremely over
optimistic at the beginning of a war and
also
have a proclivity to derogate and
minimize the strength of their enemy
and you link
so
when you did your work on self-deception
did you draw any
ethical conclusions from it
did i mean and as an evolutionary
biologist you see it as a strategy in in
a sense
but it's a strategy that has a lot of
costs
initially
i was very much down on both deception
and self-deception
i was very much biased towards
the truth
and honesty
then
i think when i saw
uh
the degree to which
uh deception was advantageous you you
mentioned
in the book having lots of examples
uh from other animals
of deceptive behavior and and even
morphology
and then
self-deception
i was against
you know doubly if you will
uh because you're deceiving yourself
so you're both the victim and the
victimizer
as i imagined it
uh then i came to kind of relax about
both of them
i saw situations in which deception
is something i
would practice
uh
consciously you know
but again
it might have to be a fairly serious
situation
in which you would have to
construct a serious lie
to get out of it
and i know there have been situations in
my life
not too too long ago
where i've spent a lot of time
constructing a deception
that gives off the minimal amount of
cues
so that
hard it's
detect if you will
when i walked my clients through
situations where they had to construct
deceptions
to
avoid let's say some serious consequence
or maybe to gain some serious advantage
which often backfired in the long run
one of the things that seemed useful to
do was to trace back into their story
the events that led to the necessity of
the deception
you know i there's a canadian songwriter
who wrote a line that struck me in this
regard he said there is no decent place
to stand
in a massacre
and my response would be
well you should unpack the actions that
led you to be there to begin with right
because sometimes there's no good way
out of something but there might have
been a good way of not having it arise
in the first place
[Laughter]
there's no decent place to stand in a
massacre
does that include the victims
well that's a good question isn't it
you know if you've been a victim
let's say you've been a victim and
genuine victim
i saw this in my clinical practice a lot
as well
despite the genuineness of your
victimization it still might be useful
asking yourself if you did anything that
you could change that increase the
probability of that victimization
increase the probability that it did
happen
yes that you were victimized
you know you you might say for example
you might want to address your
vulnerabilities
you know so here let me give you an
example okay
imagine that you
i had clients like this they were women
who had been in sequential abusive
relationships
yes
okay so they were victims and often of
extremely violent and sometimes
psychopathic men
yes
and what but what i would help them do
because i couldn't deal with the
psychopathic men they weren't there
was to
unpack elements of their actions and
assumptions that might have increased
the probability that they would enter
into those relationships
i can remember cases
uh though not in much detail now
where i notice a particular woman
who seemed to go from abusive
relationship
to abusive relationship
so she would sometimes
flee abusive an abusive relationship
literally by
uh changing the city she lived in
this is in the u.s
but then
what was so striking to me was
i would visit her or see her
she was not an intimate
a friend of mine
but a close friend if you will or
potentially close friends and i would
see
by god she's she's gone and found
somebody else
that's abusive in this new situation
so she's drawn to them in some way or at
least she's not averse to them you know
she she doesn't have her guard up
and she may indeed
um
be attracted to some element of them
that is associated with them being
abusive
i'm sure
given your clinical practice
you must have examples of this kind of
stuff here's something to think about in
that regard
oftentimes women who find themselves in
those situations
aren't sophisticated enough for one
reason or another to distinguish between
power
aggression and
competence and so when they see someone
acting aggressively
they infer competence
so part of unpacking that would be to
help them distinguish between those two
to know that there is a distinction
between the raw expression of power
and competence well there's
another
i had no idea that that was a
that that confusion was involved in
in the behavioral problem we're talking
about
uh but certainly jesus christ is the
difference between confidence and abuse
okay well let me i was speaking with um
an evolutionary psychologist david buss
yes just yesterday
and david buss has looked at the
relationship between
dark triad behavior so that's narcissism
machiavellianism
and
aggression
i might have the third one wrong but
that's basically it
now
younger women younger inexperienced
women
are much more likely to be attracted to
dark triad guys
and that's partly as far as i can tell
because they haven't had the experience
to distinguish between
narcissism let's say
and
success and the confidence that comes
with success
and that's an example of that inability
to distinguish between aggression and
competence
now the aggression might be necessary to
deal with free riders
and cheaters
so you're saying are you that some of
these aggressive men might be attractive
to women precisely because they would be
hard on the malevolent types you're
talking about yes exactly exactly that
the capacity for male aggression is
necessary and it's part of what makes
men
attractive to women you can see that in
their fantasies
so the most common forms of pornographic
fiction
that women read feature surgeons
pirates
vampires billionaires
and unfortunately i can't remember the
other one but but they're men who have
you could say power
but that's not it i don't believe that i
believe it's something like competence
and the ability to use aggression when
necessary
and then the narcissistic men
they're
parasitizing that
in some sense they're mimicking that and
that's why they're attractive to
inexperienced women
plausible
sure
when i see
the political arguments that take place
now
the accusation that the male hierarchy
is a let's say oppressive patriarchy
right an exploitative
structure
what i see in that is partially this
inability to distinguish
between power and competence
and also to unders failure to understand
when aggressive action is necessary and
desirable
and that seems related to the free rider
problem
yes i hear you
no objections to that
[Laughter]
and none so far
all right so let let me go back to the
idea of belief dependencies
so you know we all say that some things
are more important to us than others we
hold them more dear
so
it the integrity of those core beliefs
i
think is related to directly to the
inhibition of
negative emotion
inhibition of what
of of negative emotion
anxiety particularly and doubt
so
the beliefs that are more important to
us
are beliefs that
other beliefs depend on and when they're
threatened
it's very emotionally destabilizing
and
very hard on us from a physical
perspective as well
because when our core beliefs are
disrupted we don't know what to do and
therefore we have to prepare to do
everything
that's the emergency response right
that's fight or flight i suppose but
it's very physiologically costly
and so i think sometimes people engage
in self-deception so that they don't
have to undermine their core beliefs
and and disregulate themselves like that
that seems plausible to me sir the
unfortunate
problem seems to be that
the long-term consequences of that are
often not good
you know you ignore
a profound danger at your peril
it saves you from
the psychophysiological exhaustion in
the present but
if the problem is really there things
unravel really badly in the future
yes
so
we could say that self-deception
has its advantages
uh even as an adaptive strategy and
i think the idea that it can serve
deception
as a handmaiden say is a powerful idea
but it doesn't look like it's an optimal
strategy and and so one of the things i
wanted to ask you is
is there
justification and evolutionary biology
for you know you said strategies compete
right
and so does that mean that there's an
optimal strategy that
that we approximate that we
that we have an intuition of even
god i would tend to doubt
that there's an optimal one
first of all if there were an optimal
strategy why isn't everybody
adapting adopting it
uh well
you may answer me by saying well
uh
it's adaptive but not in all situations
fine but uh
if it's always adaptive in these
situations you would expect them to
get matched up together
or
fairly quickly over time wouldn't you
that's a good objection i mean it's a
tough one right i mean you you've also
talked about runaway sexual selection
okay so
this is an answer to the problem you
just posed possibly
i mean one thing that does seem to have
been selected for that operates across a
very wide range of contexts at least in
human beings is something like general
intelligence
you know and the cortical expansion that
produced that and that's been selected
by women so i would say
as a domain general there's a domain
general ability that might have been
selected that that worked in most
situations and that was more
intelligence at least with humans
that doesn't address the ethical issue
exactly
and you said it was mostly being
selected by women
female choice well they're choosier
yes and they're
they're socially brighter
and they're also they are also less
likely to
agree
that a low intelligent sexual partner
would be acceptable
according to
david buss the evolutionary psychologist
i was speaking with just yesterday
so they are women do appear to be
exerting more selection pressure on
general cognitive ability
but i also wonder if there's not an
ethical equivalent to that that
something like well the capacity for
reciprocal altruism
so what's your what what are you then
saying that females
uh
are a positive selective force for
uh reciprocal altruism i'm i'm on well
yeah well i'm that's not as strong an
argument as the one for let's say
intelligence
it's harder to define
the central element of reciprocal
altruism than the central element of
intelligence it's harder technically but
you know that there is an idea in in
in evolutionary biology sort of implicit
that
women select men who are higher as high
as they can manage in the status
hierarchy
and that hierarchy
is
constructed as a consequence of the
exercise of power and i think that's
wrong and and dangerous that idea i
don't think those hierarchies the male
hierarchies
that influence female selection are
based on power
i think they're based on something more
like competence and i think it's
associated with this capacity for
reciprocal altruism because you want
them if you're a woman you want a man
who's productive but also generous
certainly i don't have anything to say
against what you just said
um
i don't know what david buss was arguing
well so i would say something similar i
mean your your book on deception and
self-deception is very interesting
because you point out
in many many ways how deception can
confer
at least a temporary advantage but often
a more permanent advantage
and so
it makes making the case that
let's say something like honesty is
selected for much more difficult
but i also wonder if
there's a
utility in
differentiating between
deception and mimicry in animals
no terminologically
but i don't understand uh
why mimicry
is not an example of deception
let's say we're talking about maws
or butterflies
and
predators birds
so
you will have some
uh butterflies
that are
perfectly tasty
to birds
but
there are
a couple of that are not
that have a
poison that they ingest uh
when they're caterpillars
which they retain in adulthood so that
they're distasteful
and poisonous so then they attract
so to speak
mimics
because now if you're related species
uh so you're similar in appearance
already but you don't happen to
have the poison
then you evolved to be
to resemble that species
more and more
in order to gain the benefit
that they have from having the poison
so the the predator makes the assumption
that you've got the poison
because you look exactly like
the species that has the poison
and then they've done work but i you
know it's long ago disappeared from my
memory
they've done work on a relative
frequency
of the two kinds
and there are situations in which
the mimic can be
you know five or ten times as frequent
as the model
as they're called
and they're gaining a benefit
and they're inflicting
a marginal cost
on the model
there are other situations in which
as they rise in number they mimic
uh they inflict a cost
on the model because
now birds uh
snap the model of course they spit it
out
but that doesn't uh help the model
uh that just means the well the bird
doesn't swallow the poison
you could make a similar case for
narcissists
imagine that the model
is
someone competent and confident
and maybe assertive because of that
and productive and generous but the
mimic
just mimics the confidence and
assertiveness
and then there is a cost inflicted on
the model because if there are enough
narcissistic mimics
then the existence of the model starts
to become doubtful
you're absolutely right
and there's a there's a rich literature
on that
and i used to study it very carefully
because i was interested in
the you know the interaction between
deception and detection of deception
and of course
you toss in self-deception
to bypass the initial
the initial problem did i tell you about
uh
the fact that uh deceivers
have a slightly higher pitch to their
voice
yes you mentioned you mentioned that
that's very interesting
do you know anything about the
physiological mechanisms is that a
stress response or did anybody study why
that is
it's stress
due to
fear of detection okay
that's believed to
cause you to to contract your
your belly
uh when you're making a sound and so it
it it it rises in pitch
as a side note an interesting story from
your book
you
you talked about one species of
butterfly
that could lay five different kinds of
eggs
to mimic five different kinds of
poisonous butterfly species
right
so
let's talk about mimicry for a minute
and deception
because it's such they're so tightly
interwoven
human beings are very imitative
and so
someone growing up can choose to mimic a
particular model let's say and that
model might be someone competent or it
might be someone narcissistic
and so
you could mimic competence and become
competent or you could mimic narcissism
and become narcissistic
and that's partly why i think maybe
there's a useful distinction to be made
between mimicry and deception
i mean
not not in the cases you raised with the
butterflies but in the human case
because
there are psychological mechanisms
involved the problem becomes a lot
thornier
what's the definition of a narcissist
you can define it by personality
so narcissists tend to be
extroverted
a lot of positive emotion
and
disagreeable so
very little empathy
and
more likely to be
aggressive
so
and that is a masculine pattern to some
degree because men are more extroverted
than women especially in extra in in
assertiveness
and they're less agreeable than women
it's the extremes though when you get
the extremes there you have something
like temperamental narcissism
and then if they're low in
conscientiousness that's even worse
because then
well
they're neither productive nor dutiful
nor honest none of those and maybe
that's psychopathy
maybe it's it's not clear
and then
you could think about it socially is
that a narcissist is someone
who assumes
his or her status is higher
than those around them would
claim
there's a there's a there's a very
important literature
on psychopaths
because i i found i i
it was transformative
when i read these papers
they were written by
canadian mathematicians
and there was a psychopathic scale
that someone had invented
robert hare i believe invented the scale
well
psychopaths
there are violent psychopaths and they
are of course of a considerable danger
but they are outnumbered by non-violent
psychopaths
and their their definition
i think has to do with uh
lack of uh empathy
lack of feeling for others
a non-violent psychopath according to
this canadian literature
uh they studied
was it the propagation of exploitative
psychopathic behavior
in populations where there was no
punishment for free riders
the reason is because
i was thinking that oh crook
was that the name that people know you
were mentioning someone else in canada
right
yeah hair developed the scale but he he
didn't do the work you're speaking of
okay crook
so let me hit the document now
i believe the paper you're referring to
is
nepotistic patterns of violent
psychopathy
evidence for adaptation whether crook
at al also
did the held at a one to three percent
frequency in a population
there
the notion was that the psychopath
is held in a frequency dependent
equilibrium in other words
it doesn't go down to zero
because when there's only one percent
that's a psychopath
they're positively selected
compared to the general population
however when they reach three percent
frequency
they're already bumping up against the
upper boundary
so they're selected
you could also imagine that when their
frequency declines in a given population
that
people are much less alert to the
possibility of psychopathy and so then
the deceptions that they engage in are
less likely to be detected and they
spring back into existence
well yes but remember
that that that's automatically
true
about these uh psychopaths because
they're held between a one to three
percent frequency which is low
as i as i mentioned in that just a
little paragraph there
in other words
uh there
when you're a psychopath you're always
appearing
and uh and uh
but the the percentage is only one to
three percent
whereas
um
the population itself
is only experiencing a psychopath
once every several generations
so selection is bound to be weaker
on the detect detectors of psychopaths
although
the fact that uh
it doesn't rise above a three percent
frequency
does suggest
that
at that frequency
there's too damn many of them
and so people start paying attention
the fact that you just laid out two
that even when psychopaths are
relatively successful in a population
they don't exceed three percent
also indicates that
that psychopathic exploitation
which might be regarded as the purest
expression of arbitrary selfish power
is actually not a very good strategy
well
i'd rather i'd rather be the
part of the 97
that
uh wasn't a psychopath
i just found the uh
the whole argument of crook uh very
powerful because
these
psychopaths sure acted as if they'd been
under selection
because they
they favored their relatives
yeah i didn't know that about
psychopaths i didn't know that see
because
well psychologists when they're talking
about psychopaths they tend to generally
assume that there's zero
social relatedness governing their
behavior the fact that they favor kin is
extremely interesting i wasn't aware of
that yes indeed um
and uh
classically
you know psychopath
is like a as a negative trait
uh where you and i aren't psychopaths
we have the positive trait
it's just like any other thing where
there's a negative three
that's held at a low frequency or it's
at a low frequency but basically
it's being forced down to zero but what
this literature said was
for these psychopaths it's not being
forced down to zero
if it gets down to one
it's being bounced back up
it probably ice
uh oscillates between five and
and a half or something like that
but when it gets infrequent enough
it's definitely beneficial
to
enough to stay in the population you
know
well it could well be that effectiveness
at low frequency
the effectiveness is dependent on the
low frequency so you might wonder what
happens to societies where the
psychopath incidence
exceeds say five percent like
do you suppose those
societies get exceptionally punitive
what do you suppose happens to knock
down the psychopath percentage
that's a good question my friend
and i don't have any answer
off the top of my head
so this paper that you cited one of the
conclusions is that
in light of wakefield's 1992 definition
of mental disorder evidence that
psychopathy retains nepotistic design
features is at odds with psychopathy
being a mental disorder
given that a diagnosis of mental
disorder tends to be positively
associated with the victimization of
genealogical kin
it's not the case with club's work
absolutely not
and you you see uh
uh figure after figure
uh with different uh
relatedness categories and showing
that the psychopaths are
are treating them better
oh oh right it's how how much
they score on the psychopathic scale
so the higher they score on the
psychopathic scale
the more they are biased towards
relatives yeah that's really that's
really something that's really
remarkable i didn't know that and that's
a that is a huge finding and i can see
why it it it
it showed up on your radar yes
and it's also a very interesting
definition of mental disorder that
you can tell if someone suffers from a
mental disorder because they victimized
genealogical kin
yes
that's what that's not the only criteria
obviously but
but it's an interesting criteria for a
definition
yes and it's not true
of psychopaths they don't victimize
do you suppose that
the
exacerbation of nepotism
is actually part of a psychopathic
strategy
do you think you could go that far
well
i'm this paper has made me wonder about
the relationship between nepotism
as a phenomenon and psychopathy per se
so do you suppose that if psychopaths
are more likely to be nepotistic
is the reverse true
are radical nepotists more likely to be
psychopathic
i radical nevertheless like
that that i
that i don't know
what do you think the best evolutionary
theories have to say about the
persistence of homosexuality
especially among men
one of the most interesting
subjects
has to do with the repression
of uh
homosexual
tendencies
and uh
it applies especially to jamaica because
jamaica is violently
uh
against homosexuals
they're
they're murdered
uh
and uh
they they have to hide
uh
and so on
but anyway
um
what was i gonna say about homosexuality
evolutionary theory yeah
um
so there was a
there was an excellent paper published
in georgia the state of georgia in the
u.s
you you documented that in your book i i
know the study i believe it's
they gave them a homophobia scale
and then measured their penile erection
erectile response to homosexual
pornography
and found that those who were most
homophobic according to the scale
showed
a significant increase in erect
erectile
function
during exposure to the homosexual
pornography quite distinct from those
who were less homophobic
yes and what they did was to
they showed them six six-minute
films
and the first
was on uh
a man and a woman making love
and then they graphed
the penile
growth
in the
homophobic and the non-homophobic
and
they were
statistically identical
then
they
showed them a six-minute movie of two
women making love and it started taking
off like
a man and a woman but for
a certain reason
it's sort of
uh leveled off
again
there was no difference between the two
categories of men
now the third one
was the interesting one
that's where they showed him six minutes
of two men
getting it on
and
the
non-homophobic men
showed a small and statistically
insignificant
increase in
penis size
so in other words they didn't respond at
all
statistically
whereas
the homophobic men
started
and then they climbed and then they kept
climbing
and they got two-thirds of the way up
to the level at which they responded to
two women
and
yet uh they denied any uh homosexual
tendencies
these were all men that uh rated
themselves as
never had a homosexual
experience never had a homosexual
fantasy
and never even had a homosexual thought
or so they said
so
that was a fascinating result that h.e
adams i believe is homophobia associated
with homosexual arousal
probably it is
are you aware of that paper
only since i i think i've heard of the
paper before but i reacquainted myself
with it when i was reading through your
book today right
don't know if it's been replicated but
perhaps i don't know i don't know that
no i well i don't know of it being
replicated but
you know again i'm
the stage in life where i'm not keeping
up with uh
with new work
well i really enjoyed talking to you and
i really benefited from your work and
scientifically and practically and i
appreciate very much the fact that you
talked to me today and
all right jordan if there's nothing else
it was a pleasure talking to you and
god bless you and keep you
thank you very much sir very nice
talking with you
you